my name is Margaret leinen I'm the vice
chancellor for marine science and the
director of Scripps Institution of
Oceanography at the University of
California San Diego I'm at the
conference of the parties this year as
part of a large group of people that are
promoting the importance
the oceans the oceans have been missing
from any of the the dialogue and the the
agreement in cobb and the reason we
think that's so important is number one
the oceans are absorbing ninety percent
of the heat that's resulting from the
co2 emission
number two they're they're absorbing
almost thirty percent of the co2 so they
have a very important role on our
coastal communities on fisheries and so
forth a great deal would look like an
agreement to fold emissions at a level
that would give us a 1.5 degree increase
in temperature I think that's ambitious
given what I've heard so a good deal
would be one that I had an agreement
that would hold us 22 degrees centigrade
paper ease this doesn't mean a total
change in our lifestyle it means a
change in the way we get to that
lifestyle once we set this as a goal
we're going to see a tremendous amount
of activity from business from
innovation from fine
to help us reach that goal and that's
certainly something we're seeing here a
cop really strong stand out positions by
private sector business private sector
finance